the attack on our rights is shocking and
it's the social consequences of this are
unspeakable really I mean people are not
going to comply they're not compliant
now I'm sure you know this in fact
you've probably attended them but there
are speakeasies and all over New York
City popping up where you can go to
dinner and gather on more than five more
than ten even thirty people you know and
and they're drinking they're having
dinner together they're they're in
defiance of the law friends of mine in
Manhattan sit in their penthouses and
and every night at after nightfall
people rush out into the streets with
noisemakers just to just to illustrate
that they believe in freedom it's very
interesting to me that you use this word
right you've been using this repeated
our right to assemble the right to
assert our right to speak a right is not
something that's contention it's
something that you actually possess it's
not granted to you by the government
something you own by virtue of each
Manatee it's hard to talk about rights
in these times and we don't apparently
have the right to our own property
because the government can shut down our
business on grounds that it's unofficial
right we'd probably don't have the right
even to leave our homes that so once you
take that away I mean Dave I don't want
to be alarmist about this or anything
but look from a softcore into a point of
view we are living the practical reality
of what comes very close to being a
totalitarian state right now now
fortunately Thank You political leaders
you're letting the grocery stores work
fortunately they're private you know
thank you for letting us have pharmacies
you know they're they're private
entities too so we're grateful for a
little bit of private private private
private market satella
but but the attack on everybody else in
the end the attack on our rights is
shocking and it's the social
consequences of this are unspeakable
really I mean people are not gonna
comply they're not compliant now I'm
sure you know this in fact you've
probably attended them but there are
speakeasies and all over New York City
popping up where you can go to dinner
and gather on more than five more than
ten even thirty people you know and and
they're drinking they're having dinner
together they are there in defiance of
the law friends of mine in Manhattan sit
in their pent houses and and every night
at after nightfall people rush out into
the streets with noisemakers just to
just to illustrate that they believe in
freedom you know and for God's sake are
we not doing not believe in freedom
anymore I did the politicians presumed
that we're we're like pieces on a
chessboard they can just move around but
you know what it's not true that is not
the human mind we are not inanimate
objects we're not birds and cages we
will live free one way but so what would
you say so of course I'm with you but
what would you say to the people that
would say but all of those people your
friends that are going out onto the
streets at night and the people that are
getting together at speakeasies and
going out more than they have to go out
and the rest of it in exercising their
rights and freedom that those are the
people who are gonna keep this thing
spreading because people don't know what
when to rein in their own personal
responsibility and and do something so
that you know society doesn't crumble
something like that
you know at the at the had in the
Enlightenment you know where we
discovered this idea to human freedom
there was also disease we didn't have
very clean water the you know there were
annual viruses that came along and
killed people and and there were
pandemics and so on but they still
somehow came to believe that human
beings have the right to speak had
associated trade and we work around it
and and and part of the belief and
freedom is the confidence that society
has the intelligence to deal for things
like viruses that come along and the
existence
of disease does not disable the whole of
modernity
it just doesn't we can't think this way
modernity was for the time and there
were diseases and even back to the Black
Death
then in Venice and in the thirteenth
century when it was there were still
interest they still kept trade going
there was there was there was some towns
would come up with the restrictions and
that sort of thing but but the idea of
violating people's rights fundamental
rights to live and choose and speak and
everything was even unthinkable five
hundred years ago I mean the are respond
with done here is is pre-modern its
medieval its its its eleventh and
twelfth century style stuff except with
21st century technology and we're not
responding to the things as
scientifically even you know even the
slightest bit their response by the
political class and I mean from about
March 15th
onward was nothing short of mystical
superstitious I was a panicked response
let's just let's just throw everybody in
a cage of their own creation and and
punishing anybody for coming out of it
and I I just I totally forgive people
who are going to these speakeasies may
you could say that
prudent you know they shouldn't be doing
that but for God's sake people
exercising their fundamental rights I'd
say we need more of that not less of
that right now do you think that's
that's partly just human nature that so
many people just operate purely in fear
so you know like a month ago when we had
that two-day window where suddenly
everything shut down out of nowhere you
know they announced the entire NBA
season was canceled and then they
cancelled all these public events and
and everything sort of happened at
within a two-day thing that there
becomes this odd rush to cancel because
you don't want to be the one guy who's
going against the crowd right you don't
want to be the one guy who says no we're
not gonna cancel our season we're not
gonna cancel all of our things we're
gonna wait it out a little bit knowing
that the risk that you take of being
just destroyed by the media and
everything else on the other side is
probably worse than
just going along with with with the
crowd with the wave yeah I I understand
your plane I have my doubts that there
was any public support for this actually
at all
now it's entirely up to private venues
whether or not they want to you know
have these gatherings or accepted
liability associated with NBA games or
South by Southwest you know and that
sort of thing
South why is Southwest didn't choose to
set to cancel that conference that was a
governmental decision so I'm looking at
this and I'm not saying whether that was
maybe South by Southwest should have
canceled you know I don't know I think
about this a lot I'm not actually sure
about that because that's mostly all
young people there who aren't actually
not in any great danger from kovat so
I'm not I'm not sure about that and it's
hard to do counterfactuals here but with
this much Dave I know and I think you
know to politicians by which I mean
governors mayors senators and
congressmen and so on I'm not owners of
anything their main job is to get
blocked it again that's it so they don't
really have a financial economic stake
they don't have skin in the game apart
from the desire to get voters to vote
for them again and there was a sudden
panic on the part of political leaders
at all levels really that if anybody
died while they were in office that they
would somehow be blamed for this unless
unless they just bludgeoned people you
know and ruin people's lives so they
somehow believed it was less risk to
steal people's property and arrest
people in their homes than it was to to
to be blamed for a public death and and
that that gets us back to a problem with
began this discussion the role of the
media here because what they're really
fearing ultimately is is is this
canceled culture you know the the
Twitter mobs and and in the New York
Times editorial page and and and and the
media culture that's this last lost all
rationality and clearly clarity they're
they're afraid of being the
outstand and dragged through the mud and
and John and quartered and so on by the
press
so I ultimately I feel like the perfect
nor do you doesn't that feel of just the
end of the media that we've all been
seeing and as you said before you didn't
even want to see it but that so many of
us have seen the end of mainstream media
we've watched our academic and political
institutions crumble and then something
like this comes in and just takes the
last remaining foundation of it and then
adds fear to it and you take just
fearful people who don't even understand
what their rights are as you alluded to
earlier and then you really have have
the perfect storm to control everybody
now I I like this phrase the perfect
storm and I think it's the best
description to explain what's happened
to us really it wasn't it wasn't really
a conspiracy and from the top but of
course you know there's conspiracy
theories like will never stop them you
know they've been generated by the day
and if I'd totally forgive that people
wanted one understand what happened to
their freedoms what's happened to their
rights were why did the world go dark
suddenly then people assume there's some
central plan I don't believe that
actually I think it's just this
gradation of factors and I I've been
wanting to kind of write about this Wow
but yeah it is a perfect storm it was a
howling media panic politicians and just
this onslaught you know come combined
with a lack of information but I've
described an epidemic crisis that led to
a complete panic but we're gonna be
we're gonna be spending the next ten
years trying to figure this out if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell